bonsoir madame lebel bonsoir beaucoup de
projets une grosse année devant vous au
gouvernement dans l'ensemble du
gouvernement mais pas de main d'oeuvre
on le répète on leur dit et le conseil
du patronat le redis aujourd'hui les
solutions pour la main d'oeuvre ne sont
pas là est-ce que ça devrait pas être la
priorité économique de votre
gouvernement mais c'est effectivement
une prière c'est au coeur du
développement qu'on veut faire et la
priorité c'est ce qu'on peut pas avancer
nos entreprises peuvent pas avancer
alors qu'on a une pénurie de main
d'oeuvre on le voit moi j'ai dans mon
comté le j'ai beaucoup d'entreprises qui
ont peine à remplir way avoir de
l'expansion parce qu'elle faisait à
trouver de la main d'oeuvre des fois
qu'ils moins qualifiés ou d'autres sites
de main d'oeuvre qualifiée donc ce sont
des solutions aujourd'hui on annonçait
pas dans le discours des solutions mais
l'intention du travail et le premier
ministre bien dit on doit travailler à
fournir 50 ans plus tard des
travailleurs et non pas des emplois donc
on veut développer sur mon collègue le
ministre du travail va présenter bientôt
un plan il ya des secteurs plus
névralgiques que d'autres c'est sûr que
j'entends parler d'immigration ça va
faire partie des solutions je pense que
c'est pour les la seule ça serait
vraiment partie des solutions me semble
que monsieur legault a été quand même
très incisif sur cette question
aujourd'hui en disant que notre capacité
d'intégration est arrivé à sa limite en
même temps je vous ai sorti quelques
chiffres la jeu juste les montrer à
l'écran quand on regarde l'évolution des
personnes de 25 à 54 ha au québec depuis
2011 on est en baisse de 2,2 pour cent
alors qu'en ontario on est en hausse de
5% puis en colombie britannique et en
alberta on est en hausse de 10% on a
besoin de gens au québec pourquoi
l'immigration ne fait pas partie de la
solution mais c'est parce qu'au québec
on a une situation extrêmement
particulière faut faire attention le si
le poids relatif de l'immigration par
rapport à la population québécoise qui
est maintenu et je pense qu on a une
certaine capacité d'intégration mais
faut respecter le fait qu'on a on est
une nation francophone en une langue à
protéger donc on a on doit intégrer
mieux nos peines nos immigrés on doit
aussi faire un meilleur appareillage
entre les besoins du marché et le type
d'immigration elle vaut faire partie des
solutions un fait partie des solutions
mais ce n'est pas là solution unique
ladern bassin de travailleurs vous avez
parlé tenté d'entrée de jeu là en
introduction de des travailleurs
expérimentés mon collègue aux finances
annoncera des mesures dans ces très
certainement de quoi ils y travaillent
pour voir comment on peut mieux attirer
sur le marché du travail le garder plus
longtemps sur le marché du travail nous
travailleurs expérimentés et les jeunes
également qu'on doit orienter dans les
secteurs névralgiques en trop vous avez
parlé autour des technologies de
l'information ça fait partie des
priorités je comprends tout ce ballet
demain développe ont requalifié nom que
tu travailles à face à tuer un concept
vieux pas de problème avec la
requalification tout le monde est
d'accord avec ces mots ce que je vous
dis c'est que notre croissance
démographique elle est faible on un
vieillissement de la population qui plus
important qu'ailleurs au canada
présentement et nos 25 54 ans sont en
baisse et comme structuré dans notre
économie comment on fait pour avoir plus
de gens pour pas ralentir notre
croissance économique mais vous parliez
des migrations c'est ça qu'il faut
également mettre l'accent sur
l'immigration des étudiants étrangers
qui vont venir sur sorte servir sa part
dont chercher une qualification ici puis
vont s'intégrer est resté dans bonnie ça
que vous faites partie des solutions
avec une situation particulière au
québec où on voit également protéger
notre langue notre spécificité on doit
le faire correctement donc ce sont des
enjeux qui ne sont pas faciles vous
l'avez dit c'est au coeur de nos
préoccupations et vous allez sans raison
faut aider nos entreprises parce que
présentement mais la clé c'est pour la
création d'emplois mais c'est la
création de mes 2 si je peux l'exprimer
comme ça donc il va falloir travailler
et celle annonce que au fait aussi
premier ministe dans les priorités ça
faisait partie des priorités son
discours de mettre l'accent sur cette
rareté de main-d'oeuvre y trouver des
solutions pour nos entreprises c'est
chez legault a présenté comme étant une
bonne nouvelle pour les québécois le
fait que les québécois puissent demander
des hausses salariales vous savez que du
côté des entreprises il ya certains qui
es-tu delà de l'inflation salariale est
ce que les entreprises est ce que c'est
une bonne nouvelle aussi pour les
entreprises la pénurie mais
écoutez il va falloir trouver des
solutions on le dit pour faire soutenir
nos entrepreneurs il ya beaucoup
d'enfants prise où on veut les soutenir
l'automatisation des entreprises vous
avez vous savez très bien où ce n'est
pas possible mais on va falloir aussi
soutenir nos entreprises pourraient
dépenser dans cette compétitivité de la
main d'oeuvre où on doit frais mais on
peut pas dire que c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle pour un travailleur où il ya
sept cette compétitivité là où il peut
avoir accès un meilleur c'est un
meilleur salaire dont avoir une
meilleure qualité de vie donc si on peut
pas nier
les entreprises qui savent qu'ils seront
pas capables si on passa à 17 18 20 22 $
pour des salaires qui sont généralement
plus bas il ya des entreprises feront
pas capable d'offrir ce
vous avez raison et c'est pour ça qu'il
va te falloir trouver des solutions pour
les soutenir et voir comment on peut les
aider aussi à faire peut-être un virage
technologique ou en innovation pour être
capable d'avoir un meilleur rendement et
peut-être compter - sur la main d'oeuvre
à ce moment pour l'instant votre
stratégie semble beaucoup passé sur de
meilleurs salaires pour les enseignants
pour les infirmières pour les
éducatrices en garderie vous êtes au
coeur de sa bien sûr comme président du
conseil du trésor
jusqu'où vous êtes prêté un livre parce
qu'on a ça peut coûter cher un moment
donné pour l'état québécois
réitéré raison puis vous allez
comprendre que je ne révèlerai pas me
marge de manoeuvre mais vous voyez la
stratégie des dom non elle est dans les
priorités gouvernementales qu'on a
identifié puis c'est la première fois je
pense qu'il faut il faut le répéter aux
québécois c'est quand même si tu aurais
où on ne fait à travers les cinq cent
mille travailleurs de l'état cap on
comptait deux grands réseaux éducation
santé on a mis de l'avant des
négociations différencier donc c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire le
gouvernement dit ce ne sera pas la même
hausse salariale pour les 500 mille
travailleurs de l'état c'est ce qui nous
a permis de pouvoir mettre l'accent sur
certains secteurs qu'on a jugé
prioritaire qui sont les secteurs vous
avez nommé naturellement pour qu'ils
soient pas par des hausses salariales
mais ça passe aussi par une
réorganisation du travail c'est au coeur
de la stratégie gouvernementale en
négociations présent et on va suivre
aussi la mise à jour économique qui
viendra un peu plus tard avec les
ministres girard merci beaucoup madame
le but d'avoir été avec nous un plaisir
merci bonne soirée à tous pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit